it looks much like a regular night in a
regular pub but this where the spoons in
Twickenham is doing its bit to save our
oceans it swapped all its plastic straws
for paper wonders and next year every
business will have to go even further
all plastic straws and plastic starers
and cotton buns to be banned by April
2020 introducing the ban Environment
Secretary Michael Gove said urgent and
decisive action is needed to tackle
plastic pollution and protect our
environment these items are often used
for just a few minutes but take hundreds
of years to break down ending up in our
seas and oceans and harming precious
marine life so today I'm taking action
to turn the tide on plastic pollution
and ensure we leave our environment in a
better State for future generations this
now iconic image has come to represent
nature's losing battle against
single-use plastic it's prompted the
government to act but environment
charities say it's still not enough we
know that these three items do turn up
on our beaches they're normally in the
top 10 most commonly found items on
beaches but it is just three items there
is a lot more kinds of plastic pollution
out there we have plastic coming from
our clothing it's even in paint from the
tires on our cars you know plastic is
everywhere so we need a lot more action
from the government skies ocean rescue
campaign has been instrumental in
drawing attention to the plastic
poisoning our seas the company's chief
executive Jeremy Derek welcomed the
government's decisions he said
single-use plastic is a disease of our
own making we're working hard to get rid
of it and completely agree with Michael
Gove that urgent and decisive action is
needed it's estimated that we use up to
4.7 billion yes
billion plastic straws in England every
year and even though there are so many
alternatives available like metal or
glass or paper 95% of all straws in use
right now are still made from plastic
but that will now change awareness of
the issue is driving consumer behaviour
somebody gives me one at a bar I'll say
please Stowe but then they'll throw it
away if they put it in your dream
they'll just throw it away so it's good
replace it with paper you see the
protests in London even a month ago
people are stepping up and asking what
why is this can we do anything to
improve something as small as a straw
you know we can all do our part and it
makes a big difference in you we're only
just beginning to understand how much
damage single-use plastic is doing to
our planet but the warnings it seems are
finally being heeded and not before time
now she's Joshi Sky News